we've created a simple hello world app
for Python so you can quickly get a feel
for deploying an app engine standard app
to Google cloud platform before I
started I made sure to install the
Google Cloud SDK and the App Engine
Python components locally in the cloud
console make a new GCP project and
create an app engine application choose
the region closest to you in my case US
East one I'm going to do this project in
Python and the standard App Engine
instance works great
first I locally cloned the hello world
Python app from github everything you
need is in the Python Docs sample
directory including this minimal Python
file to handle the response to the HTTP
request the simple llamo file included
starts the app which you can view on
localhost start the app and then test it
by visiting localhost 8080 to see that
it's working hooray
you have hello world now you can leave
the development server running and make
changes they'll be automatically
detected the server will reload
automatically after I make any code
changes let's change the text in main
dot pi and watch good morning so deploy
to App Engine run g-cloud app deploy it
picks up the project you created earlier
and will upload all the relevant files
to GCP once that's finished you can
check out the app in your browser with
g-cloud app browse and now you're live
on appspot comm congratulations that's
it you've deployed your first App Engine
app
[Music]